[Applaudissements]
nous sommes en janvier 2009 dans ma
boîte aux lettres le courrier d'un
inconnu
chère madame j'ai bien lu votre livre
les recettes de mina et c'est pourquoi
je me permets de vous envoyer quelques
documents qu'ils ne vont pas manquer je
pense de vous étonner
ils ont mis 60 ans à sortir des placards
et des coeurs ce sont les notes de
déportation de mon père marcel letertre
décédé en déportation dans les camps
avec 400 recettes de cuisine
veuillez agréer madame l'expression de
ma considération signé emile letertre
lorsque je reçois ce courrier je vient
en effet de publier un livre sur
l'histoire d'une femme tchèque qui dans
le camp de terezin a écrit un carnet de
recettes pour sa fille partie en
palestine
la première fois que j'ai rencontré
cette histoire j'étais absolument sidéré
peut-être comme vous l'êtes maintenant
de voir ces deux choses mises côte à
côte
quand concentration et recettes de
cuisine c'est pourquoi j'ai voulu
absolument raconté dans un livre et dans
un film cette histoire extraordinaire et
unique et voilà que le courrier des 1000
le tertre m'apprend que si cette
histoire reste en tout point
extraordinaire elle n'est plus unique
d'autres carnet de recettes ont pu être
écrit et dans d'autres camps est
certaine même écrite par des hommes ce
que je n'aurais jamais pu imaginer alors
je saute dans le train pour nantes et je
vais rencontrer et me letertre et le
carnet de son père et ses camarades ils
étaient résistants français ont été
arrêtés déportée dans le camp de fle en
saxe à la frontière entre l'allemagne et
la tchécoslovaquie
là il devait fabriquer des ailes d'avion
des ailes de messerschmitt
petit à petit au fil des jours ils ont
dérobé à l'atelier du papier des petits
morceaux de papier plein de petits
morceaux de papier
et puis aussi une mine de plomb ils
l'ont caché précieusement et le dimanche
après-midi seuls moments de repos
un groupe d'une trentaine d'hommes se
réunissaient et s'échangeaient des
recettes de cuisine que marcel letertre
de sa jolie écriture et petite écriture
ce qui était précieux vu le peu de
papier dont ils disposaient écrivaient
les recettes de cuisine et puis un jour
ils se sont aperçus que ses recettes
allait être fragile et qu'il fallait
faire quelque chose pour les protéger
alors ils ont volé à l'atelier les
chutes de métal pour ça il aurait pu
être pendus ça pouvait être du sabotage
et les recettes s'étaient trop précieux
il fallait les protéger alors le
dimanche
dimanche après dimanche ils ont écrit
ces recettes
il y avait parmi eux le poète robert
desnos avant la guerre il avait écrit un
précis de cuisine des jours heureux
c'était une fine gueule et il avait très
peur que les français perdent le goût
des bonnes choses avec les rationnements
alors il avait écrit ce petit fascicule
et à ses camarades de fle 1 il a promis
que quand il rentrerait quand il serait
libéré il publierait ses recettes qui
serait alors un imprécis de cuisine les
jours peureux vous remercie
épinards à la béchamel rima
l'impératrice rillettes de lapin
bouillabaisse soufflé à la crevette
salade de riz des fruits macarons
galette des rois moules à la béchamel
gâteau économique pains au lait de
beurre brioche alors trouver un carbet
de plus je me suis dit qu'il devait y en
avoir d'autres et je suis reparti à la
quête est assez vite j'ai rencontré
l'histoire des digues en bus edit second
but c'était une juive de hongrie raflé
dans la rue et envoyés d'abord à
auschwitz puis à ravensbrück arrivait
ravensbrück au cours d'une sélection
elle réussit à faire valoir qu'elle
parle bien l'allemand alors on l'envoie
à l'usiné ims qui jouxte le camp et elle
travaille avec l'ingénieur en chef
là elle arrive à voler du papier du
crayon également et elle écrit
nous avons commencé à parler de ses
plats magnifique que nous échangions
autour de la table familiale en des
temps meilleurs
en parlant de serre pas rêver avalions
notre salive et d'une certaine manière
nous étions refus c'était mon idée de
faire ce carnet parce que je ne savais
pas même faire cuire un oeuf
je me suis dit que ce serait un bon
point de départ dans la vie parce que
j'étais catégorique
j'allais survivre à la dernière page de
son carnet edit note une recette de
gâteau de mariage
un pressentiment peut-être puisque en
effet ai dit tu as survécu à la guerre
et qu'elle est partie en australie avec
ce carnet pour unique bagage
sur la droite nous ce qu'on ne fait que
chez nous c'est une toile moosehead dry
femme aline sous cape to cape ne savent
plus à evans chose j'en ai fait des
carnets écrits dans les camps nazis j'en
ai retrouvé un certain nombre
j'en ai retrouvé à fle à à ravensbrück
beaucoup à ravensbrück à neuengamme him
he made her à birkenau
clairement on n'était plus dans
l'exception alors je me suis demandé si
cette écriture si singulière avait lieu
seulement en résistance au système
concentrationnaire nazi aussi d'autres
sommes mis dans un contexte
concentrationnaire qui utilisait aussi
la fin comme moyen de coercition avait
pu avoir recours à ce type d'écriture
j'ai pensé bien sûr au goulag est ce que
dans les camp de travail soviétique
les détenus avaient pu aussi écrire des
recettes de cuisine la recherche était
assez difficile notamment parce que je
parle pas russe mais finalement de
hasard en petit miracle j'ai rencontré
l'histoire de vera nicolaï et vabec
sadien vers a été mariée à un diplomate
arménien qui a été fusillé dans les
toutes premières purges de staline mais
elle n'en savait rien elle savait juste
qu'il était condamné à perpétuité sans
droit de correspondance à l'époque elle
ne savait pas personne ne savait que ce
sens droite correspondance signifiait en
fait qu'il avait déjà été fusillé mais
elle elle voulait l'attendre donc elle
était dans son appartement moscovite
avec leur petite fille et elle attendait
au cas où petro serait libéré n'a pas
suivi le conseil de ses amis qui lui
disait qu'il fallait qu'elle fuit et
donc un jour elle a été arrêtée pour
n'avoir pas dénoncé les activités
contre-révolutionnaires de son époux
elle a été arrêtée et elle a été déporté
dans un camp en mordovie
ap hautement à potsma on demandait à
toutes les femmes qui étaient là qui
étaient dans la même situation qu'elle
qui étaient en général des femmes
éduquées qui n'avait pas dénoncé les
évitez contre-révolutionnaire de leur
mari on leur demandait de faire du
bûcheronnage dans des conditions
climatiques que je vous laisse imaginer
et puis aussi profitant de leur
éducation leur a demandé de faire de la
broderie la légion il veut même que
certaines de ces broderies été exportées
alors quand on verra et ses amis ont
commencé à discuter recettes de cuisine
et qu'elle voulait les noter elle
n'avait pas de papiers impossible d'en
voler il n'y en avait pas moins quand
alors elles ont eu l'idée de voler des
chutes de tissus et donc à l'atelier
elles ont récupéré des chutes de tissus
qu'elles ont littéralement couverte donc
le premier qu'elles ont littéralement
couverte chaque centimètre carré de
recettes de cuisine
après dix ans de caen vers a été libérée
elle a cousu son drôle de carné dans son
jupon et il est rentré dans sa famille à
moscou où le carnet est toujours
[Musique]
alors je dis que finalement c'était
assez logique qu en europe
on avait cette tradition culinaire et
que donc un peu partout en europe on
avait eu recours à cette écriture mais
les hasards de recherche d'internet -
venez de l'autre côté de la terre où
j'ai découvert que les soldats
américains prisonniers dans les camps au
japon pendant la deuxième guerre
mondiale avait eu aussi recours à cette
écriture
c'est le cas du sergent war in stewart
donc j'ai retrouvé le carnet dans sa
famille en alabama sergent stewart a été
prisonnier pendant trois ans et demi à
kawasaki
un camp dans la banlieue de tokyo et là
il a écrit un incroyable carnets qu'il a
intitulé chao than recipes bouffe 0,7 à
l'intérieur des tas de recettes
et puis chose que je les retrouve nulle
part ailleurs des listes des listes et
des listes comme s'il voulait se
souvenir qu'il y avait autre chose que
du riz et des têtes de poissons dans
l'univers alors il fait des 64 liste de
soute 57 liste de légumes
et puis les listes de dessert des listes
de noix des listes de pain et des listes
de bonbons
dans l'une des dernières pages de sky
sports ce sera l'anniversaire de son
père prévoit tout il prévoit le lieu dit
qu'il faudra que ce soit à l'ombre près
d'un cours d'eau claire et puis on y
mangera bien sûr des apéritifs
on y mangera des olives fourré de
fromages épicés
on y mangera du pain de maïs on y
mangera une salade de pommes de terre
on y mangera des darnes de bach on y
mangera des salade de crevettes et puis
bien sûr un gâteau chocolat coco avec
des bougies dessus et puis encore un
sorbet à la cerise et on fumera des
cigares white rose
alors pourquoi pourquoi toute cette
énergie pourquoi tous ces risques pris
pour une littérature d'apparence bien
peu héroïque quelques hypothèses d'abord
tout le monde peut se souvenir d'une
recette de cuisine et la partager pas
besoin d'être un lettré pas besoin
d'être un poète
pas besoin d'être un musicien tout le
monde peut se souvenir et partager des
recettes
et puis dans les camps il y avait une
règle d'or qui était de ne jamais parler
de la vie d'avant ne jamais parler de la
vie heureuse et donc les prisonniers ont
vécu dans une promiscuité absolument
inouïe en partageant les machines les
latrines les gamelles et sans rien
savoir de leurs camarades ce qu'ils
avaient des parents des enfants ne
savaient rien peut-être que c'était
d'ailleurs dangereux parce que quand on
était tout seul dans son coin et qu on
repensait au jour d'avant souvent ne
s'en relevait pas ça semblait à tout
jamais tellement inaccessible qu'on ne
pouvait pas se se relever de ça c'était
pour ça qu'il y avait cette règle d'or
et que jamais il ne fallait évoquer les
jours heureux
mais là le fait d'être ensemble que ce
soit un partage de faire quelque chose
puisqu'on devait l'écrire peut-être que
ça rendait le souvenir possible se
souvenir de ce qu'on mangeait à noël ou
ce qu'on mangeait
lors de l'anniversaire de la tante lucie
ce qu'on mangeait lors des fêtes
religieuses etc et des spécialités
gastronomiques des uns et des autres
dans leur région alors peut-être que oui
et recettes de cuisine elle crée un
billet et rendait possible ce souvenir
est le rendait même nourrissant et puis
il faut garder en tête que ses recettes
elles ont lieu dans un univers qui est
complètement chaotique qui est
complètement absurde qui est d'ailleurs
voulu comme tel parce qu'ils ont pensé
ce système parce qu'évidemment rendre
fou de rendre de faire perdre leurs
repères ou des portes eh bien ça les
rend plus servile donc on va vous
demander un jour de vous épuiser à
déplacer un tas de pierre de là à là et
le lendemain évidemment vous allez
devoir leur maître là on va vous
réveiller en pleine nuit enfin mille et
un exemple d'absurdité peut-être que les
recettes dans leur ordre dans leur liste
d'ingrédients dans leur séquence de
préparation elle apportait finalement un
petit peu de d'ordre et de paix dans ce
chaos
et puis peut-être qu'elle apportait
aussi la variété qui va avec la liberté
primo levi disait que finalement les
jours les pires n'était pas forcément
ceux où on était obligé de d'assister à
l'exécution de camarades mais que
c'était finalement la grisaille d'un
jour sur l'autre qui donnait ce
sentiment de perpétuité et que c'était
ça finalement le plus difficile alors
peut-être que les recettes en apportant
un jour des tomates
le lendemain des petits pois du veau de
la fricassée de poulet etc
elle ramène de la liberté au milieu de
cet enfer concentrationnaire alors moi
je fais l'hypothèse bien sûr tout le
monde n'a pas écrit des recettes de
cuisine mais je fais l'hypothèse que
c'est un phénomène universel puisque
j'ai trouvé des carnets écrits par des
hommes autant que par des femmes par des
jeunes par des plus âgés par des
hongrois des russes des américains des
français
et quand je suis allé voir l'historien
michael byrns groupe home qui est un
grand spécialiste de la shoah et que je
lui ai montré ses fac similé
ils étaient très étonnés ils avaient
connaissance du premier carnet sur
lequel j'avais travaillé le carnet de
mina pachter mais là il était assez
sidéré de voir que ça avait pu exister
dans autant de camp et dans des
circonstances aussi différentes
il a pointé quand même une spécificité
peut-être des carnets écrits par les
déportés juifs parce qu'ils avaient
compris qu'on voulait les détruire on
voulait les faire disparaître eux les
humains mais qu'on voulait faire
disparaître aussi leur monde leur
culture et leur monde et peut-être que
ce monde
il trouvait là une sorte de résumé une
sorte d'écrin alors peut-être est-ce
l'explication à ce cri lancé par
minappech teurs dans son carnet des
raids 70 buts s'il vous plaît prenez
soin des recettes
merci
[Applaudissements]